[Music]
[Music]
welcome I'm Philip Sharpe and it is a
real pleasure to be able to introduce my
colleague Eric Lander to present a talk
on the historic event of the sequencing
of the human genome when historians look
back on these decades of biological
science that bracket the change of the
century and the millennium the most
noted advance will be the sequencing of
the human genome this sequence will
shape all biological and medical science
that is done post genomic and in fact it
is the definition of that word post
genomic the consequences of having the
sequence will not be fully realized
until decades have passed there are many
stories for MIT in this event first as a
story of Eric Lander educated at
Princeton as an undergraduate PhD in
mathematics at Oxford then a faculty
member at Harvard in the business school
his first relationship with with MIT as
a fellow in the Whitehead Institute
studying human genetics shortly
thereafter he became a professor in the
Department of Biology and a member of
the Whitehead Institute he began the
human genome project at MIT and his
director of the human genome Center
which is affiliated with the Whitehead
Institute the second story is the
relationship between the Whitehead
Institute and MIT this relationship
which began and a highly debated
experiment some 15 years ago has been an
unqualified success
the Whitehead Institute has produced
great science some of which we celebrate
today has produced great leaders in
science and has played a full role in
education at MIT as typifies by Eric's
outstanding lecturing in the core
biology course here in 10 to 50 which he
does in the fall finally there is a
story of the human
sequence what it tells us about our past
and future how the sequence was
determined in an international effort
and what it will mean for humanity this
story will be told by Eric the
scientists who led the team that
contributed the largest portion of the
sequence to the public effort and who
has been its best spokesman MIT can be
proud that one of its faculty has
accomplished an historical first the
sequencing of the human genome
[Applause]
let me start by oh but I have no voice
by the way one of the casualties of this
week which has been a rather intense
week is that my voice seems to have been
lost somewhere between here in
Washington so those of you who are used
to my lecturing in 701 may detect a
somewhat more painful version of it
today but dankest let me correct one
thing film said right at the end because
I think it's very important one of its
faculty members has has completed the
sequencing of the genome of course and I
know Phil means it what happened is
about 250 people here at MIT in the
Whitehead Institute have completed this
remarkable project of sequencing the
human genome because I think one of the
really most important aspects of this
project is that nobody could do this
alone this was the first example of a
truly truly collaborative effort of
enormous proportions in biology and I
don't think it will be the last of those
efforts I think we've learned that there
are projects that we need to get them to
provide the infrastructure for our field
to provide the the tools that the single
smart graduate student and postdoc can
use for her or his experiments and that
we need to work together to make those
tools and I think before I go anywhere I
want to say how tremendously
tremendously honored and pleased and
proud I am to have gotten to work with
so many people here together in this
community to get this job done and any
one of us had a small part but what I
can say definitely is if we here at MIT
had not pulled together to do this it
wouldn't have gotten done and that's a
pretty good thing if not any one of us
was essential to us this community was
absolutely essential to it so this is
very much a shared talk but I'm very
honored to talk about it on behalf of
all the people here who did it I'm
looking out upon that the community
members the genome Center here which is
great I see 701 students here some of my
701 students because I'll actually here
in the fall and I'm glad to see you back
again and many of my colleagues in the
biology department and they're probably
a whole lot of people who are not
biologists at all who just came because
they were interested to find out what in
the world was going on with the human
genome project I'm gonna try to be able
to speak appropriately to everybody and
and just talk a little bit about what
went on what we've learned from it
and where it's all going we just dive
right in the human genome project and
beyond the human genome project was
absolutely ludicrous notion proposed in
about 1985
maybe 84 85 that we could determine the
entire sequence of the human genome and
that this would provide incredibly
useful information for all of biology
both of those propositions were open to
tremendous challenge the first that we
could do this at the time DNA sequencing
was less than a decade old DNA
sequencing was practiced with
radioactive slam gels held up against
film the detect sequences it was
stunningly inefficient it was not that
long before that point that people got
whole graduate theses for sequencing of
a couple of thousand letters in some
plasmid and here the field was talking
about a million times more sequencing
than that in addition it was hotly
debated whether this was worth anything
at all
everyone not Evert many people said well
why don't you do with that information
anyway who needs it
and the truth was with regard to both of
those propositions the critics were
right we had no clue how in the world to
do this if anybody had gotten up in
front of Congress and said we know how
to sequence the human genome they would
have been guilty of perjury thank God
nobody had to say that under oath to get
this project started and if anyone said
we know exactly what we're gonna do with
the information they would have been
lying to you too but what happened was a
marvelous process of scientific progress
in the latter part of the 80s when a
number of different committees in a
number of different countries and a
number of different discussions got
together and refined this project from
what it was first some mega project into
a number of steps that would produce
intermediate results that would
immediately have feedback to science and
would involve dozens and dozens of
groups around the world this is just the
timeline of some of the events with a
mammalian centric point of view because
we here at MIT in white
have taken a mammalian centric point of
view of building the genetic Maps that
let you trace inheritance that was the
first thing just landmarks not so many
of them a few thousand that would let
you trace inheritance of families making
those Maps better and better through
three different generations shown here
in colors then once you've found by
tracing inheritance there's a gene in a
particular region you would get the
piece of DNA by a physical map from that
region and you would study it to try to
find the disease gene but then of course
what you'd really like to do is sequence
all those pieces of DNA so that instead
of having to do lots of laboratory work
you would just double click with your
computer and up would pop what you
wanted that of course being the dream of
biology experiments in 1985 oh sorry
1996 began a pilot project for the
sequencing effort when a number of
groups around the world got together and
said we try to work out the
methodologies for doing large-scale
sequencing being able to do the process
at high quality produce finished
sequence at the end to automated and
this was designated as about a three
year pilot project and that is indeed
what happened in the spring of 1999
there was a dramatic scale-up because we
entered the production phase and over
the course of the next year or so the
vast majority of the sequence got
covered it involved a tremendous change
in technology when we began in borrowed
space in the Cancer Center we were using
single channel pipe headers the great
advance following that was eighth
channel pipe headers some favored to
twelve channel pipettor but over the
course of the decade or so we advanced
and advanced to the point where now the
genome center over the Whitehead
Institute is filled with robots of this
sort there are picking robots that go
around with cameras picking bacterial
clones that had their pics 96 colonies
dunks it in to grow at pix 96 more in
the course of a day we pick about
120,000 bacterial colonies we then have
to grow them up overnight and we have to
purify them many of you in the audience
have done plasmid preps before and then
set up sequencing reactions it's a
tedious operation this is how we do them
now this is the production floor for
setting it for doing plasmid preps and
sequencing reactions on to those
conveyor belts which use a new kind of
biochemistry a solid phase reversible
mobilization it was developed at the
genome Center on to these conveyor belts
go microtiter plates of DNA of bacteria
of growths they had cracked open the DNA
gets precipitated it gets washed and
cleaned in all different ways reactions
gets set up into chugs along at a pulse
rate of one microtiter plate about 96
clones per minute through this system
processing a hundred twenty thousand
clones in the course of a day you see a
trend is a number of machines in this
picture you see only a handful of people
and that is correct
the remarkable development team over at
the genome center that built to this
robotics in conjunction with it with a
company in fact is significantly larger
than the number of people it takes to
run the robotics which is really quite
quite delightful once all of this
sequence comes at once all the
sequencing reactions come off we have to
detect them and they go back to a room
of commercial detectives back in the
back room we have a farm of about 145
capillary based sequencers with a
throughput of about 65 million letters
of DNA per day that's a lot of sequence
per day and then all of that goes
upstairs to the informatics department
where folks process this and assemble
this and extract something from all the
sequence it was a very interesting year
from May of 1999 to May of 2000 when the
amount of the genome that had been
covered in draft form not perfect form a
draft form has grown grew from about 10%
of the genome to about 90% of the genome
in the course of one quite remarkable
year this is roughly what the year
looked like here that was month by month
the genome and I could just look at this
for again and again and again it's just
really a let's look at that again that's
really
it's really fun there you go that's all
there is to sequencing a genome now this
this involved a tremendous amount of
coordination of twenty different groups
around the world distributing clones
groups working at all different sizes
our group at the Whitehead interest
Institute was indeed the largest single
contributor to the effort but in fact
there were there were major major
contributions from the Sanger Center in
England from Washington University in
st. Louis from the Department of Energy
from Baylor in Texas and then a number
of small groups all of whom played I
think incredibly important roles in
keeping this an international project in
fact the project was so open that that
halfway through its its scale-up phase
the group in Beijing China said they
wanted to join and we said sure and
Beijing brought in one and a half
percent of the genome done there in
China the groups are all very different
in how they approach this but they all
shared one absolute commitment which was
that the data however it was produced
would be freely released on the web
every 24 hours without restrictions of
any kind that was the only condition for
signing up to join the International
Human Genome Project it was a pleasure
to work with all these people and it was
a pleasure to to do all this work and
I've got to say there's just absolutely
nothing like just being able to be left
alone and focus on your science and this
was absolutely nothing like being able
to be left alone and focus on your
science we spent the entire year while
we're trying to sequence the genome
waking up to newspaper headlines all the
time because apparently I understand
some company decided that we were being
slow about it and decided to create a
business plan that they were gonna
sequence the human genome so much faster
than anybody else and they would
therefore have a proprietary database
that they could do with this they chose
to my mind there was a little
miscalculation
there in that I think they mistook what
was the designated pilot phase where
we're attempting to figure out how to do
this thing carefully and write for an
inability to scale up when we were ready
and so in fact I think some would to
their surprise they found that we were
zooming along just fine doing this and
that the the
business plan which involved having
three year window where the sequence was
exclusively available through this
company really seemed to well it didn't
look so good after a while welcome back
to what actually happened is
scientifically there was a lot very
interesting stuff there there were some
claims that they were gonna do this by a
much more powerful method the
much-vaunted whole genome shotgun method
that instead of dividing the genome up
into pieces they were going to toss the
whole genome into your blender press you
know puree and and be able to sequence
lots of pieces and put it together and
this was so much faster than the silly
old you know know where you are and get
the whole thing organized kind of way
well we're gonna come back to that point
because for the first time we know the
answer of what actually happened but
given all the controversy of what was
going on we decided that the best thing
to do I believe senator Aiken really
gets credit for this strategy was simply
to declare victory right this was the
old Vietnam strategy right in his case
was declare victory and withdraw we just
declared victory and went back to our
labs to get to work you know finishing
the genome back on June 26 there was a
big announcement at the White House that
the human genome had been sequenced at
least if you read closely that a draft
version of the human genome had been
sequenced and if you were it really
closely that the groups claim that a
draft sequence of the you come obviously
in our case you could check the web
yourself and see that there was data
there or there you'd have to analyze it
yourself
the case of the company you know go
figure how would you know anyway but it
didn't stop the announcement and it was
basically right because there had been
an amazing milestone achieved which was
that it was no longer the case that the
lack of sequence was a rate limiting
step for biology that for the vast
majority of regions of the genome you
could get your hands on the sequence but
what we hadn't done is analyzed that
sequence put it together neatly seen
what's in it really read through the
book and to my mind although I realize
it's a seems sort of pokey and
old-fashioned instead of science by
press release to me the real milestones
come with peer-reviewed papers and
that's what in fact happened this week
that's what was exciting this week was
that a paper appeared in the issue in
the journal Nature in fact a remarkable
collection of about 20 papers appeared
in the journal
nature one of which cut reports the
sequence of the human genome and an
initial analysis some others report
other related topics I'll talk about it
appeared officially covered it yesterday
we held a press conference on Monday to
announce this and this picture here by
the way is one we designed here at the
Whitehead Institute you may not be able
to see closely but this is a picture of
DNA that has been decomposed through the
photo mosaic technique into 100 to 1,500
human faces from around the world and so
when you get your issue of nature look
up close we did this here in fact we had
this idea of doing this here then we
searched the web to find out where in
the world was that company that made
these photo mosaics and it was
absolutely delightful to discover that
this this company that I've heard of but
never really paid enough attention to
was the product of an MIT graduate and
was in fact two blocks down just by the
neck olfactory and so MIT pops up all
over the place you know it just it was
great anyway for fun go try to find the
picture of Crick and Watson in this
picture there there is a Where's Waldo
to this so it's there all right so a
little bit about assembling the sequence
of the human genome IRA as many of you
aren't aficionados for this stuff
I think I'm scheduled to give a proper
seminar in April this is you can tell
it's not a proper seminar this is kind
of fun to celebrate this week assembling
the sequence of the human genome very
briefly we had to produce and we did
produce this is largely the work of bob
waterston ask Reubens st. Louis
overlapping clone Maps across the genome
of large inserts clones each about
200,000 letters in length and then to
select from that a reasonable tiling
path of these large we call them back
SPECT Arial artificial chromosomes these
large 200,000 base pair clones break up
each of these things into small shotgun
fragments sequenced them and reassemble
them into a draft form that still had
some gaps but a modest number of gaps
perhaps eight nine gaps something like
that and then with computer programs
merge them all together into overlapping
sequences based on where we knew these
clones were and it's there's a very nice
program written by a graduate student
that UC Santa Cruz called Jim Kent
called
assembler that put all these fragments
together in some nice way and the short
version of this is that there's a fair
amount of continuity you start initially
with about 20 to kilobase contigs of
sequence merging them you get them at 80
to kilobase context connecting them by
links you're up to about a quarter of a
million bases they live within larger
clone context that we have localized all
these fragments into that extend for
more than two million bases and connect
to about five million bases and then are
joined by fingerprints into a bed eight
million bases and so in fact there's a
hierarchical arrangements of each of
these fragments connected in there are
still gaps throughout this map but we
know where the vast majority of those
gaps are in fact almost all of those
gaps 99 percent of the sequence is well
localized to the human chromosomes by
this process it ain't perfect it ain't
finished but for every letter in the
sequence we've attached an error rate 91
percent of the letters in the sequence
are accurate to 99.99% ninety-five
percent are accurate to 99.9 percent the
order we've checked it against all the
previous maps available in degree is
pretty darn well although there are the
occasional differences in the order
where we've checked those differences so
far they appear to be problems with the
previous maps in fact the sequence seems
to do a pretty good job of cleaning up
the previous maps rather than vice-versa
but by no means will we assert that any
of this is perfect there's still
probably about a year and a half's more
work to go to bring this to what we call
finished state but already is an awful
lot of genome there the connected pieces
of sequence the scaffold the the
sequence are connected to scaffolds and
together they they span about 2.9 to
billion bases which appears to be about
the entire euchromatic portion of the
genome there's problem the genome is
probably a 3.1 billion bases the rest of
it being heterochromatin around
centromeres and other regions now over
the 2.9 - we seem to have about 2.6 9 in
our assembly that's about 92 percent of
the genome seems to be represented in
our assembled bases there are gaps
there's been hundred forty nine thousand
gaps in the sequence but all but 2000 of
them we have immediately spanned by
pieces because they live
well within clones and they are all
going back through a finishing process
and getting closed up because of the one
there's wonderful mapping approach that
was taken all these pieces happen to
live within a mere two thousand
components that have to be put onto the
map and the number of physical gaps
where we don't actually own a piece of
DNA covering it right now is under a
thousand those are being worked through
so that's a rough description in any
case this is all just to say it's not
done but it's pretty far along it's
pretty far along then there were our
friends at the company so I keep reading
in the New York Times how they beat us
at this thing it was really really fun
this week we got to read the paper so
they really did try their whole genome
shotgun thing it generated a whole lot
of data in the house about fivefold
coverage they report no assembly of it
whatsoever I assume from the fact that
nowhere in the paper if they attempted
to assemble their data that it didn't
work at all instead what they did if you
read the paper and I invite my
colleagues now to read the paper closely
was they took their coverage and they
took the whole public database based on
seven and a half fold coverage they
didn't even break it up randomly or
anything they got out the screwdrivers
and they carefully unscrewed it into a
perfectly overlapping tiling path with
exactly equal big overlaps tossed it
into their computer and then added their
data and attempted to assemble a genome
sixty percent of the data that went into
the computer was ours it was not
experimental data
it was simulated data simulated not even
as you do in a laboratory but with
perfect overlaps wish I knew how to
generate data like that in a laboratory
nonetheless nonetheless the whole genome
shotgun still failed despite all that it
covers about 75% of the genome in
context that you can really localize if
you ask how much does it cover total
here's what it looks like they call it
the word foe is there word in the paper
there foe whole genome assembly
has about 88% of the sequence in it
although it is in a hundred and nineteen
thousand separate pieces that have to be
localized far beyond what you can
localize if you take the biggest ones
you can get about 75 percent of the
genome realistically localized and about
25 percent of the genome is in its the
technical term is tossed genome salad
the so the assembly that actually got
reported by our friends although this
makes no difference in the New York
Times was not that whole genome genome
assembly what they did instead when they
realized they had trouble with this was
they simply said alright we'll take all
our data we'll lay it on top of the
public clones in a clone based assembly
and we'll just assemble the local bits
so instead of a whole genome assembly
they did assemblies on the order of
about half a bacteria log that however
did work of course but it produced was
about 2.6 5 billion bases of DNA the
input to that of course was our 2.6 9
billion bases of DNA and it produced
about the same coverage the genome so I
yeah I mean I don't need to make a big
deal out of this difference this is
basically the same so I think in fact
what they did was they rearranged our
sentences within our paragraphs or
something like that I must say after
putting up with 3 years of science by
press conference it is a pleasure to
read a scientific paper and find that
what really happens and I gotta say
there were some pretty dark times in the
course of the Human Genome Project when
we felt should we just throw in the
towel was this really possible to put up
with a steady drumbeat of press telling
us that we're being silly for being slow
and wasteful and all these things in the
end there would be no slur paper but for
the Human Genome Project and you know
what we're very proud to have put our
data on the web and let them have our
data and all that the only thing I ask
is that they probably ought to do a
better job of acknowledging you know why
they have an assembly but they're
welcome to the assembly the data is
there for everybody even for those who
would like to say that they're competing
with us are beating us that is the one
great thing about making your data
freely available is because you have no
chance of meaning because you give
everything to your competitors you
absolutely are guaranteed to have no
choice
of losing and that's important because
we have to win by giving this stuff away
alright interpret
it's a good lesson interpreting the
sequence of the genome so I don't put
aside all that stuff and say well what's
energy gnome anyway well a lot of people
around the world combined their efforts
and put on all the different annotations
we know there is a browser at the
University of California Santa Cruz
where we display all the different RNAs
that are known all the es T's that are
known all those similarities to the
pufferfish tetsuro Don and Mouse's going
on in the next month or two
all the repeat sequences and anything
else you want to know about the genome
either the folks at Santa at Santa Cruz
here's the Santa Cruz browser if you if
you visited you can zoom in or zoom out
according to your preference you can
scroll along the chromosome you can you
know set it for what which things you
want to see which things you don't want
to see and if you have any suggestions
for for what else should be there let us
know and it'll get added in addition
because we believe in diversity the
European bioinformatics Institute has
its own version of this browser same
sequence is used here but they put it up
differently they have different
approaches to how they're annotating it
the National Center for Biotechnology
information also is bringing up a
browser and there'll be a lot of diverse
ways to look at this sequence there is
also when you get your copy of nature
this way to look at the sequence we have
a fold out fact to roll folds that come
out of the journal with the human genome
on it showing the the key features like
the density of G's and C's and sign-outs
and line elements and also all sorts of
things it is it is I must say not at a
terribly useable scale it's at a scale
of 3.3 million bases per centimeter
which is beyond my visual acuity but in
any case but it looks pretty to put up
on your wall but you notice certain
things from effect going back to it you
can see if your eye is really good that
the G's GC content which is this black
line goes up and down a fair amount the
genes there's some dense urban
neighborhoods of genes some rural
neighborhoods here of genes if you plot
it the genome is really lumpy we're very
lumpy compared to other species there
are there are regions where the G your
average GC contents 41% there are
regions where it takes an excursion up
by 10 or 15% for periods of 10 million
bases before it comes back down again
and you know even a little bit of
statistics will tell you that this can't
possibly happen by chance in fact there
are very distinct neighborhoods the
gc-rich regions appear to be gene rich
in fact we have now great data about a
gene which they are they also by the way
correlate to many other things such as
chromosome banding pattern there's a
very strong correlation where the
gc-rich
regions correspond to the light bands
and chromosomes and in one of the
companion papers to come out in
yesterday's issue of nature one of the
the consortium groups put about 8,000 of
the back clones that had been sequenced
onto the cytogenetic map and drew these
correspondences which is useful both for
the general statement but also for say
cancer genetics where one can take
cytogenetic rearrangements and correlate
them not a sequence because you have
8000 time points now you may know that
most of your genome is not genes in fact
only about one to one and a half percent
of your genome is genes most of your
genome or repeat elements they're repeat
sequences they are transpose ax bilal
ament's that have inhabited our genome
and hopped around over the course of
hundreds of millions of years from their
point of view that's the purpose of our
genome is to carry around them because
they certainly are the majority occupant
they were they were and they consider
the genes a you know necessary detail in
order to propagate the transpose of
elements and all that but when you when
you you go back to 15 years ago people's
AG you know the repeats they're boring I
might have actually thought that to even
five years ago but I gotta say they're
unbelievably interesting these repeats
very briefly almost all repeats near
genome fall into four flavors one are
called line elements what are called
sign elements what are called LTR
retrovirus like elements one are called
DNA transposons for example on line
elements or one of the great inventions
in the history of eukaryotes they're a
transpose ax Balewa meant they make an
RNA that goes off to the cytoplasm and
it's to open reading frames it gets
translated into protein the protein
grabs the RNA that made it brings it
back to the nucleus cuts the chromosome
at a site and reverse transcribes it
back into the chrome
it's a completely self-contained package
for making an RNA getting the machinery
translated coming back to the nucleus
and copying yourself you'd think the
ultimate parasite sign elements
interestingly are parasites upon the
parasites they encode nothing all they
do is they make an RNA that doesn't get
translated there's no open reading frame
they go off to the cytoplasm the only
thing this RNA is supposedly really good
at is grabbing the line machinery away
from a line RNA and getting it to stick
it in the chromosome instead see it's
just it's just they have a lot of
millions of years to work this stuff out
and it's very clever retrovirus like
elements these things also move by RNA
intermediates by a different mechanism
they involve a gag and appalled but not
an end gene but otherwise they look an
awful lot like the mechanism of
retroviruses and indeed it is thought
that these were the precursors to
retroviruses they learn first had to do
their their jumping jacks within a cell
and then after having worked out how to
do all this get reversed transcribed
would ever pick up a cellular envelope
gene and the part then there's DNA
transposons they're very different than
the other three because they don't make
RNAs
what they do is they make they make a
message that goes all in sorry they
don't transpose through RNA
intermediates they make a message it
goes off makes a transpose days the
transpose days comes back to the nucleus
cuts the chromosome and moves the DNA
element elsewhere these guys have a very
different life than the other guys
because this is actually a pretty crummy
lifestyle if you're transpose A's well
the problem is you're transpose days
gets made out there in the cytoplasm
comes back to the nucleus and tries to
find who made it we would like to find
the element that made it and move that
element preferentially remember the line
is smart enough that the proteins grab
the RNA that made it that way you ensure
that you're moving in active elements
the bloody transposes comes back doesn't
know who to get it grabs anybody and
moves it and that's there for DNA
transposons are self-limiting infections
do this as they begin to build up extra
defective copies they become less and
less and less efficient and their lives
are short ok so that's what you got now
a few comments we can put them all into
a family tree because every element when
it hops is a copy of something that was
an active element initially its siblings
who hopped about
the same time all started with the same
sequence and then it began to degenerate
but we can by evolutionary by
phylogenetic reconstruction figure out
that these 52 sign elements are siblings
and they arose by virtue of the number
of changes that are in them about oh I
don't know five million years or ten
million years and every single element
in the genome can be put into families
and those families can be dated so in
fact we've done that for all three
million elements of the genome and those
dates are really fascinating in
particular you can find out that most of
our repeats are very very very old much
older than you see in flies or worms or
mustard weeds
this tells by measured by percent of
interspersed repeats another way to put
it those for the human genome the vast
majority of repeats in your genome
hopped before mammals hopped before the
mammalian radiation there are fossils
pre mammal and so they're quite old
things but here's a shocker despite the
fact that they've been hopping for a
billion years despite the fact that this
is you know the thing that's caused your
genome to form at the size it is the
rate of transposition is plummeting
dramatically in fact in olden days is
this working
yeah in old days here this is old moving
to now the rate of transmission was here
and went up but lately last forty
million years it has been in a plummet
in fact DNA transposons are extinct
completely extinct these rate retrovirus
like guys are almost extinct if not
extinct there's only a single family
left that is hopped since our divergence
from chimpanzees and we can only detect
three possible active elements that have
opened reading frames in a full length
if those guys have missense mutations
that inactivate them that's it they're
dead that's that's the end of the line
for l2 our retro transposition so
there's a serious ecological crisis with
regard to the you know endangered
species of transposons in our genome
right now and we don't know why but we
do know that this is not happening in
the mouse interestingly the mouse does
not show the same pattern at all
curiously its rate of transposition is
not and there are eleven happy families
of LTR retrotransposons hopping around
the mouse genome every day what's going
on we don't know if we have some
interesting speculations having to do
with the fact that it may be that our
genome that are our population the
hominid lineage has very small
population size and we're much more
subject to the effects of genetic drift
that could let you lose the small number
of active elements so as my own guess
but we have no evidence of this rodents
stands every large but much larger
population sizes and are much less
subject to genetic drift but we're gonna
have to look at a bunch more species to
know what's going on here's another
weird fact just to show you what you can
learn by staring at a genome you think
genome sequences you know I are boring
Wow here's something really weird if you
were a transposon where would you go
would you hop into gene rich gc-rich DNA
or would you hop into GA poor eighty
rich DNA well if you're as smart
transposon trying to you know get along
with your organism it'd be sensible to
hop into gene poor eighty rich DNA where
you do the least damage and in fact
that's exactly what the line element
does lines and the nucleus cuts the
chromosome at a AAT and in fact that
accounts for the tremendous enrichment
of line elements in a tea rich gene poor
regions it's very sensible sorted they
taunt between the organism in the and
the genes they're the organism and the
transposon sign elements however show
exactly the opposite pattern they are
highly enriched near genes now a that
doesn't make a lot of sense well why
should they do that and be far more
importantly from the point of view of
biochemical mechanism how do they
accomplish that because I thought I told
you they use the line in the nucleus to
move why don't they get stuck in at AAT
two hypotheses number one somehow that
RNA is so smart that it could reprogram
the endonuclease to put it elsewhere I
don't know how to do that that'd be a
fancy but a protein machinery but maybe
a protein engineering but maybe
alternative hypothesis they actually go
in and eighty rich regions but evolution
favors the retention of those that are
near genes and gc-rich regions but the
latter hypothesis that I've just
they did would imply a function well we
now know the answer because we can look
at the genome in the genome will tell us
the answer how do we know we can take
all those sign transposons and sort them
into the newborn ones the adolescent
ones the middle-aged ones and the old
ones the newborn ones have a
distribution looked just like the lines
in 18 rich DNA as they get older and
older and older there's a 13 fold
enrichment for those near genes while
there are some interpretations
alternative possible interpretations for
that we strongly favor the
interpretation that there's actually
selection going on for this and there
was a hypothesis proposed two years ago
by Schmidt that's really fascinating
that proposes the mechanism turns out
that these sign RNA is bind in a
sequence-specific fashion to a specific
protein kinase involved in the
regulation of protein translation
different organisms had different signs
but they all bind to the cognate protein
kinase mutate them slightly they don't
if you wanted to regulate protein
translation how would you do it would
you use approach oh sorry one more fact
signs
unlike other G transpose moments are
expressed in somatic cells under stress
others just in the germline turns out if
you wanted to regulate protein
translation under stress would it be
smart to use a protein because you'd
have to translate it right that's the
kind of dumb
you'd use an RNA and you'd want to have
a lot of it if you wanted to work
quickly under stress and you'd want it
to be located somewhere in open
chromatin where you could express it
easily in other words of course this is
backward reasoning but it might be quite
reasonable to use a high copy repeat RNA
located near genes if you wanted to
regulate something as a stress response
yeah any case this was Schmidt's
hypothesis he had made it two years ago
and the evidence we have now that there
is a rap that there is a rapid within 25
million years reshaping of the
distribution of signs I think provides a
very interesting bit of Cora potentially
corroborating evidence for that here's
another interesting fact you can take
transposons that were born at the same
time and used them for epidemiology you
can use them as if there were a birth
cohort and say if a transposon landed on
the Y chromosome versus the X chromosome
how does it do that right yeah that's
right
how does it do well if you if you look
at it transposons born at the same time
that land on the Y have lots more
mutations than land on the X and from
this you can infer and in fact back out
that the rate of mutation in sperm
because Y chromosomes always go through
go through male meiosis is twice as high
as in eggs because X chromosomes spend
two-thirds of their time and female
meiosis so you in fact work out the
differential mutation rates by comparing
things on the X and the y chromosome in
fact in this particular case we have the
pleasure of confirming work of David
Paige about 6 months ago there had been
a bunch of previous that he's trying to
do this that got lots of wrong answers
and David made a really nice estimate of
this about 6 months ago where he said we
really think it is a two-fold difference
based on one particular region about 4
million years ago and we can confirm
this now based on about a hundred times
as many data spread out over 40 million
years that David's David's suggested
rate of male to female mutation is spot
on there are zillions of more things I
could tell you about transposons I won't
you know I'd tell you about the fact
that we get genes from transposon so at
least 50 genes in the genome we can
recognize as gifts from transposons we
can also recognize the most recent ones
to hop the ones that are still variable
in our population and can be used to
trace the history of our population but
let me switch to genes because our
genome does contain genes and they are
of some interest we have been attempting
by looking at the sequence to identify
the gene content of the human genome
golly
that turns out to be a lot harder than
bacteria yeast or worms or flies because
there's a signal-to-noise problem our
genes are only one-and-a-half percent of
our genome whereas in flies and worms
and yeast they're you know big
proportion of a genic locust is the
coding regions 50 percent typically
whereas in us it's a trivial fraction
and so our ability to detect these is
nowhere near as good and the gene said
currently generated and described in the
paper is nowhere near as good but
nonetheless we have a pretty good handle
on how many genes there are and we
certainly do have but we do have good
chunks of most of them and the answer is
there's really only about thirty
thirty-five thousand genes
say 35,000 genes is a rough guess we've
run it through all sorts of estimation
techniques statistical estimation
techniques we've also done direct
counting programs including one written
by Chris birch here called genome scan
which is a a successor to his famous
gene scan program for finding genes
within genomes as well as a bunch of
others and all the evidence we get
points to the same conclusion about
35,000 genes so I own today an apology
and I wish to make that apology right
here and now to about seven years worth
of students in my 701 course because I
have been reporting the official number
that there are supposed to be a hundred
thousand genes in the genome and so I
don't know that you're entitled to your
money back but nonetheless check with a
register on that but nonetheless I I now
wish to correct that misimpression well
actually why did we ever think there
were a hundred thousand genes that turns
out to be very interesting we had a
track back to what was the origin of
this round nice understand gene number
the origin turns out very clearly to be
down the road it's small I Gilbert while
he did a beautifully simple calculation
in the early 1980s that a typical human
gene look like has about 30,000 letters
the genome was about three billion
letters divided one and together you get
a hundred thousand and it's so round it
made it into the textbooks it just
refused to go and of course it was only
meant to be a back-of-the-envelope
estimate if you tell this to Wally the
reaction is hey you know we're basically
right because it was it's while he's
trained as a physicist and to a
physicist the back-of-the-envelope
estimate that's within a half an order
of magnitude is just fine the problem is
that biologists you know think that a
factor of three means something all
right
and it really doesn't not by these
estimations anyway but there are a lot
fewer genes we've taken the genes we
sorted them into functional categories
and things like that we can say a number
of things about them the exons tend to
be small or the introns the intervening
space is bigger there seems to be more
alternative splicing about to full
warranty of splicing in human genes it
appears than flies or worms so that in
fact although we don't see the
depressing fact is that the total number
of genes we have at 35,000 is only about
twice as many as a nematode worm C
elegans or only about twice as many as
the fruit fly Drosophila melanogaster
and on the whole we like to think that
we're a lot more complicated than that
and so this is per oak tremendous
concern particularly the past week about
people worrying about how we can be some
complex with such an economy of genes
one answer is well we make more proteins
out of them we do more alternative
splicing that clearly does seem to be
right
oh another fact to mention is that they
are indeed theirs now we can tell a huge
huge bias to the gene gc-rich regions in
case you needed any confirmation that
there's been a tenfold enrichment there
but when we look at our genes we ask how
are they new how are they different what
what explains what makes vertebrate
genes well first off we are not that
innovative most of the domains and our
proteins they're old they're in
invertebrates only about 7% of all the
domains that we can find that
invertebrate proteins appear to be new
to the vertebrate lineages that is a
surprise
there's only one enzyme that vertebrates
seems to it seem to invent it that's
what's pancreatic ribonuclease but what
we did do to get more genes was who
created many more architectures we put
together the old pieces in many new ways
and we have considerably more
architectures for any given domain
appears with many more genes in a human
than it does typically in fly or worm
there's a particular emphasis of this in
extracellular molecules and I expect
this has something to do with the
greater complexity of our circuits is
that we connect the parts in many
different ways in addition another bit
of our rather derivative innovation
that when we like something we just
expanded dramatically olfactory
receptors the human genome shows about a
thousand olfactory receptor Llosa a
thousand we actually count 906 at the
moment that we have got well in a hand
and then there are parts missing at all
that but it's about right shows that
vertebrates showed tremendous interest
in smell it's one of the crowning
achievements of vertebrates is the
spectacular elaboration of smell
receptors however I'm sorry to report
that having done this the hominid
lineage decided that it didn't really
care about smell receptors and
two-thirds of our smell receptors of
pseudogenes
we can clearly see from the sequence
where his mouse keeps its suit its smell
receptors and pretty fine working order
by comparison we see him after all this
investment in the nose who decided to
settle on the eyes instead is a more
interesting sense and you can see it in
what we what we tidy up in our genome
immunoglobulin domains obviously a big
part of the genome we discuss some of
that intermediate filaments the 127
intermediates film and proteins
including a hundred eleven keratins if
you wanted to describe a vertebrate
you'd say it's something that really
likes epithelial surfaces all sorts of
specialized epithelia for these
intermediate filaments growth factors
were into growth factors big expansions
a number of the growth factor families
like tgf-beta so then you know kind of
vertebrates are are things that would
like to smell have immune systems
specialized epithelia and communicate
and develop with lots of growth factors
that could kind of be us we also can't
appear we appeared not to be able to
take credit for that much for all of our
genes and actually about 223 is our
count genes that we find in the human
there is no homolog outside of
vertebrates in the rest of the
eukaryotic world but there are homologs
in bacteria that is we have a close
relative in bacteria but nothing outside
have heard a brought up the likely
interpretation of this is that these
represent horizontal gene transfer that
occurred early in the vertebrate lineage
bacteria can in fact mate with non
bacterial cells and transfer DNA to
though it's usually unproductive but in
fact possibly back when were a fish some
bacteria got into some again got with
some gamete and passed some DNA
isn't a frequent occurrence but we count
about 220 three of these it's of course
conceivable that some of these are
hiding somewhere in invertebrates we
haven't seen yet and we may have to
rethink it but right now the most likely
interpretation is that these are indeed
horizontal transfers they're all enzymes
so we didn't invent them they're not
characteristic of what's gets invented
in vertebrates one of them for examples
monoamine oxidase an important
psychiatric important in psychiatric
disease now to extract all of the
information out of the genome we're
going to need to line up with lots and
lots more species and so already the
international consortium is a work on
sequencing mouse rat zebrafish
pufferfish and various other species in
a partnership between Whitehead Wash U
and Sanger we've been generating random
coverage of the mouse genome to be able
to pick out exons by cross species
homology the goal is to get about three
fold coverage we're already at twofold
coverage so I think the goal with three
fold coverage by the spring will be met
and we'll be able to line up and I think
identify many of the exons from the
mouse rather directly but I think we're
gonna be able to get a lot more than
just the exons because in fact I think
we'll be able to get much of the
regulation this way I'll give you just
one good example that emerges from
working at the genome sequence we have a
very important set of genes involved in
development called the Hawks clusters
these Hawks genes occur in four big
clusters Hawks a B C and D that all are
homologues the things that arose in
insects we've sequenced them now not
just in the human but we've done them to
completion in the mouse the rat and the
baboon when you line them up and this is
work of Ken Dewar could the genome
Center they line up speak accurately I
don't you mean good which is you'd
expect but spectacularly
that is over a hundred million years of
evolution they fall perfectly on a
diagonal
there's been no insertion or deletion to
speak of across these low sign and when
you look closely why when you look
closely you see why remember I told you
half of your genome 50% of your genomes
repetitive at the Hox cluster it's 1%
the Hawks cluster has essentially no
repeats it admits no mutation to repeat
either in the human or the rodent
lineages
there's no target for changing that that
means that spacing and content are very
tightly conserved and that suggests that
this thing is chock-a-block full of
regulation and sure enough when we line
up the different species we can pick out
more than a hundred apparently conserved
regulatory features there I don't think
this is particularly special to Hawks I
think this I think Hawks is very special
the way it's all tightly conserved and
spacing and all that but I think in fact
if we can get the correct alignments
throughout the rest of the genomes we
will be able to pick up lots and lots of
regulation that that occurs finally I'll
mention very briefly that there are a
lot of other applications of this that
are happening and that also are
represented in the papers that are that
appeared yesterday to under to apply the
sequence to humans in medicine we really
need to understand not just all human
sequence but all its variation we need
to understand what's the nature of
variation in the human species what's
the nature of those variants that cause
disease well in fact over the past
couple of years particularly at the
genome Center we've been characterizing
that we've had a project to not just
sequence the genome but begin to collect
variants we did a project made that
three years ago which at the time we
called foolishly large-scale survey of
variants in the human genome where we
reported about 4,000 single nucleotide
differences and could report that the
frequency was about one in a thousand
that Ubuntu 1,300 the typical genes had
only two or three or four common
variants in the population and then in
general we looked
despite being six billion people like we
were really a population of about 10,000
and that's right because we are a
population of 10,000 we all trace back
to a small founding population in Africa
a mere five thousand generations ago and
we show it from our DNA variation this
is of course very important because we
have a very little amount of variation
we stand the chance of characterizing
every variant in the genome maybe three
or four variants for each of 30,000
genes and testing each one for
correlation with disease finding doing
human genetics may become a simple
matrix problem right then all the
variants along the top while the
diseases along the side and fill in the
matrix and just see that would be a lot
of fun well if so in order to do that we
need various techniques I won't fuss
over these these you know there are
there techniques called Association
studies where you
directly test variants will engage
disequilibrium studies where you
indirectly test them by ancestral
haplotypes but what you need for all of
that is to have zillions and zillions of
variants the goal is to have such a
dense map of single nucleotide
polymorphisms we call them snips that
you can comprehensively test for Disease
Association anywhere in the genome by
looking for the signatures of ancestral
haplotypes enriched in people with
disease but you need a lot of them four
thousand that we published three years
ago is not much so happily a great
example of how industry and academia can
work together the snip consortium was
found founded a bunch of companies and a
bunch of academic centers got together
and said they would pool their resources
and find 300,000 variants across the
genome and put them all freely in the
public domain without cost or I or any
kind of patent protection this got going
about two years ago and it was been
wildly successful it's a great example
of how industry and academia can work
together to produce things that are
helpful to all concerned in addition a
bunch of variants come from just taking
the sequence and taking our clone based
map and looking at the overlaps so the
number of snips the number of variants
in the genome has grown from when we
reported it was right over here four
thousand and we were very impressed with
ourselves to basically the work of three
centers while she waited and the Sanger
Center and appearing yesterday in nature
was the companion paper reporting one
point four two million variants in the
human genome we now have a variant on
average every two kilobases in the
genome we will push forward we like to
get about four billion variants or so
but already we are just up to our ears
in variants across the genome and we
stand a very good chance of defining all
of the ancestral segments that occurred
in the genome and using them to trace
disease I won't tell you about I'll skip
over to a couple slides here that we've
also measured how big those segments are
and that varies with populations but in
northern Europe they're quite big on
average about a hundred kilobases in
total maybe 50 or 60 in either direction
from a point in certain African tribes
they're much smaller because the
ancestry is different in terms of the
age of the family of that population but
we're going to be able to understand
and use these for disease studies I'll
skip over those factoids
in addition and I'm not going to talk
anything about it this is this is having
this work on the genome is having a huge
effect on cancer studies as well it's
driving us in cancer studies and many
other people so look at all the genes
simultaneously in the cell and I think
the reporting now of the full list of
genes means that we're gonna be able to
make really good micro arrays to study
the pictures of gene expression in cells
finally with a pretty with for the first
time comprehensive arrays all right well
the goal has been to try to create for
biology with the chemists have had for
the whole last century the periodic
table to have the parts list all right
I'll call this stuff the holy grail and
and I'm not convinced by any of that
this is just the parts list but a parts
list is a very useful thing we are now
closer than I thought we might ever get
such a parts list we don't have fully
all the nucleotides but we will give it
but a year or so we don't have fully all
the genes but we have the vast majority
covered to the vast majority their
lengths and give it a year or two and
that'll be there and that means and we
also have by the way the isotopes the
variants on the elements namely those
snips I think it's probably fair to say
that you could already start planning
your experiments counting on the fact
now safely that all of that will be
there that the periodic table will be up
on your wall in the next year or two it
will be perfect yet it'll take oh
actually the periodic table wasn't
perfect when it first went up on the
wall they spent it's been 20 years
felling on all the holes right it didn't
cost them quite as much money back then
but they spent a lot of time filling in
all the holes right and so none of these
things are every perfect but but the
conceptual framework there is there I
think I'll have a big effect on us
before I close them I have to reinforce
what I said at the beginning this was
different than any other project in
biology when you stand up usually and
you give a talk in biology you talk
about your work or your working a couple
of graduate students or postdocs or
something like that this is a project we
there's nobody who can take personal
credit
this this is something that happened
because of the way everyone agreed to
pull together and share the work and
share the credit the group that did the
most to bring this to fruition is shown
here on the snow this is the whitehead
genome Center over in the park in
Charles Street this was the only place
we could find we could actually take a
picture there's no indoor location we
could actually manage to get the whole
genome Center and still have a camera
stand back far enough to get them but
this is the folks and one could not ask
for a better set of colleagues and
friends to have worked with over such an
extraordinarily exciting at times
stressful but always exhilarating time
and so I am a tremendous debt to my
colleagues here I will not name the
names of all 250 people associated with
this I will in particular single out
Lauren Linton who did an amazing job at
mounting a scale up for the center in
the course of this project and I do
particularly want to thank Chad Knauss
Pam bris Biron and Mike Saudi who have
been the assistant directors of the
center who have managed all different
parts of this effort but there are
heroes throughout this entire picture in
addition there were groups around the
world that contributed tremendously this
is a picture of the first bermuda
meeting that occurred is in Bermuda
really truly amongst the different
international centers and I oh great
that's the colleagues in different
countries we all are still working
together but the only really appropriate
credits slide for this talk is that this
is the first talk where you really just
have to put up the whole globe and say
we done it together and it was really
really satisfying to go to Washington
this week with so many of our friends
and realized that for something that we
had started in my case many cases 15
years ago we actually had done it not
all quite finished but we've done it
well enough that we knew there was now
no doubt it was all gonna get done and I
confess I tend to be pretty annoyed to
these sorts of things I'm not you know
one to get sappy about this stuff but by
the end of day on Monday I'd realized
that this is kind of the surprise in a
way is that only only in retrospect your
eyes have
how history ends up happening it happens
sort of just by doing your work every
day on something worth working on and 15
years later we all who have been working
together here in this community on
something just working on the right next
step in the right next step realize that
over 15 years collectively we all did
manage to make quite a difference and so
it's really fun to come this week in
particular and just share it with the
community as it's all of ours thanks
very much
are there a bunch here are some of these
right over here
I didn't hear about this
in the tone of Eric's comments I'd like
everybody who participated in the genome
Center work who's in the room to stand
up let's thank them to come on
Eric would be pleased to take a few
questions this is a big crowd that we
can take a few questions not from people
like work not some people who you can
ask me tomorrow a few please with a
fraction of genes involved in
intelligence it depends on the
definition if you mean the fraction of
genes which when knocked out disrupt
your intelligence it's probably like
we've always thought half or more if you
include being dead as being an insult to
your intelligence and it's a very large
fraction if you want to know what
fraction of the variation in
intelligence in the population is
attributable to variation in genes we
have in a clue and my own guess is I
mean this is the usual question of how
much genetic determinism of intelligence
there is there's nothing in our sequence
that tells us much about that and what I
do think I find most interesting in our
sequence is I it's a point worth making
is that the very fact that we are so
extraordinarily similar across the
species over 99.9% identical only one
difference in a thousand this holds
across the whole planet and we come from
such a small founding group tells me
that the population genetics have not
changed in five thousand generations but
we ourselves have changed opportunity in
society and what's possible and what we
think men or women or people from
different groups can do so dramatically
so I must say realizing how the gene
pool has not undergone significant
reshaping and that huge time in yet
society can come out so different that
is to say what we do with our brains and
what we do with our intelligence has so
many free degrees of freedom there that
I'm not too worried about what the
genome is ever going to tell us about
limits on what we can possibly do
because we have tremendous evidence that
within whatever limits there are we've
been able to have huge variations and a
lots within our control
sorry
[Music]
you know we have a database
repeat the question so given that that
there appear to be only thirty forty
thousand genes the question is that
there are for example ads in several
journals that say subscribe to the X
database which has 120 thousand genes so
see the markets have closed I could say
but one response potentially would be to
sell right another response would be
that the New York Times actually has
begun to probe in site pharmaceuticals
code now called inside genomics on this
question because the ad I just quoted is
from insight and according to the New
York Times the the chairman of insight I
think it's chairman the president of
insight said the New York Times this
week that oh oh we actually meant
120,000 distinct transcripts but they
actually come from 40,000 genes so in
fact that one if I take correctly what
was in the New York Times appears to
have just been retracted and it was just
the detail that they meant
transcripts not genes but Bill Hazeltine
and Human Genome Sciences is rock-solid
sure that he's got 120,000 genes and
that he's not giving any ground on that
and so I the falling refund challenge we
get to specify one percent of the genome
and anybody who wants to disagree
produces the genes they claim they have
and the one percent that we picked we'll
check them together and see if they're
right if they have three times as many
genes and that 1% then we'll believe
that they've got gold and the other 99%
but as nobody wants to take us up on it
it's it's tough to deal with the claims
yes
future priorities for other species well
what this is telling us is that
sequencing is a tremendously powerful
way to get information you never
imagined before all this repeats all
this other stuff
clearly experiment it's never gonna go
away experiment is our primary driving
force but it's a great way to form
hypotheses so my sense is already
Mouse's under way we're at us underway
zebrafish is on their way to different
pufferfish on your way i believe that
several of the organisms along the
lineage leading to vertebrates ciona and
such will be sequenced in the next
couple of years
in order to figure out what were the key
innovations chimp is a very interesting
debate I can tell you already there's
gonna be 50 million differences with
chimp yes we know what the percent
difference is I just don't know which
ones are gonna be important and there's
an active debate in the community as to
whether we should race the sequence
chimp or the we should figure out what
the world we do if we have the 15
million differences and I think what
will happen so they probably be light
coverage of the chimp to see if we can
interpret those differences most of them
are probably just noise right and if we
can figure out it's a 10 that mattered
or a 10,000 that mattered how are we
going to know before we go overboard I
have a feeling that is the cost of
sequencing comes down already yeasts
it's no big deal to do bacteria alright
and I think it's gonna soon be no big
deal to do fungi and I can't see why we
wouldn't just continue to sequence lots
of organisms as the cost comes down
because it's telling us what is the
greatest lab notebook in history
evolution it turns out has been taking
notes for 3 and 1/2 billion years and
it's lab notebook now it did not have a
good course on research practices
because because it only takes notes on
the successful experiments it throws
away the unsuccessful experiments but we
got the notes on the successful
experiments and obviously we don't want
to criticize it because it was before it
got started before these these
procedures were required of graduate
students typically but it's pretty good
okay so and I didn't really say and I
apologize in many different ways one way
make a an expression or a where you put
that a piece of DNA complimentary to
every gene take the messengers from the
cell wash them over and see which genes
are on and off by having a comprehensive
list of all genes you know you have a
description here's another way produce
full-length cDNA is for every gene and
actually express the proteins in
appropriate places if your
pharmaceutical company tests the small
molecule that has an interesting
biological action but you don't know
what its target is for binding against
all 30,000 genes and if it has a side
effect tested against all 30,000 genes
to find out with other things it may
bind to look at all the interactions
between those things I mean in some
sense it's a C do I have a periodic
table after all it doesn't define the
experiment the genome sequence doesn't
find the experiment what it does though
is it converts the search for every
answer into a search in a finite list it
means with periodic table I can look it
up in the mass spec if I know what I saw
go by and its mass and a few properties
I know what it was increasingly in
biology we're gonna be in a world where
when we see something happen we can know
what it was that just happened what
particle went by what protein it just
was whereas in the past for most a
phenomenon we were studying we had to
spend months or years figuring out what
just did that and I think what it is is
the great room through the graduate
student of the postdoc because usually
the graduate student post that said most
of their time tracking down what the
part was which is kind of boring
compared to the phenomenon now they can
study a phenomenon and the tools aren't
all there but four or five years now
maybe it'll be much easier to describe
that phenomenon and working parts and
get on to real experiments that's what
it's for
what do you think is gonna happen now
how many oh yeah one gene one protein
what's what happens to that well of
course one gene one protein is the
official doctrine in 701 but even in 701
we did acknowledge that that wasn't
always the case and that there was
alternative splicing
I mean viruses have been good at this
for a long time of being able to put
together other transcripts and such and
we've we've known about this for a long
time what it means is that you know
there will be a more intensive study to
figure out when you make three proteins
from the same gene how different are
they really they're not radically
different proteins they're variations on
a theme
typically with some extra domain and you
know I think some serious work will have
to go to that question of what this
these domains you know the extra domains
do accomplish there but I think as with
all of biology I mean the central dogma
isn't strictly right than one gene one
protein isn't strictly right but you
know it's not it's not bad it's not bad
last question sequence over the
centromere until America regions be able
to fight
so the backs that were sequenced were
prioritized not to be those in highly
repeated regions we do seem to recover a
decent number of clones for those
regions but because they tend to be
strongly repeated they got put at the
bottom of the list and so we poked our
way our head into the teal Urich and the
centromeric regions but we haven't dealt
with it now I'm not sure how well we're
ever gonna do it really cleaning up two
mega bases or whether it matters
tremendously most genomes that have been
sequenced the genes have known 50% of
the genes have no known function is that
true for the human and what steps are we
taking ah depends what you mean by no
known function if you say what fraction
of the genes have no recognisable domain
that we could achieve in being a protein
kinase I suppose there's a function but
then again for what purpose is it a
protein kinase so if you're willing to
say I know it's a protein kinase or an
eighth or or it does you know it's it's
a GPCR that counts enough 60% of the
genes we can attach functions to some
bit of biochemistry associated with gene
if you're asking what's their real role
in the body and some meaningful sense oh
golly it might be you know twelve
thousand or so might be a third of the
genes we have pretty good ideas of what
they're doing in the body and of course
even there we're often surprised right
you know April lipoprotein II that was
carrying around you know lipoproteins in
our blood system turned that to be in
our brain and and predisposed to
Alzheimer's disease
so we're it's pretty primitive we don't
know what most of these genes really do
that is the work I think of the next
decade is to attempt to find as many
ways to characterize these genes by
where they're localized in the body
under what circumstances their
transcripts are turned on you know where
they are subcellular ly what they
interact with through partners what
happens when I make a small molecule
try to bite the binds to each of them
and figure out what function I disrupt
by no means is this a comprehensive
description of life this is really I
mean I couldn't find of calling it
it's the parts list to a Boeing 777 you
know all the screws you know you know
all the seat cushions
you've got the fuel gauge you've got all
the pieces and they're all spread out on
the floor right we don't yet know how to
screw it together and we don't know why
it flies but it's sure better than if we
didn't have the parts list I shall close
with that
[Applause]